від Києва за три дні добавлять Кремль Ну
ось їх приблизно настрою зміни в настрою
чому б'ємося краще ніж багато хто тому
що в нас там чекають І ми готові бути
частиною НАТО через мову Я не буду
більший чи меншим українців це особиста
Моя думка я не знаю яка офіційна але
кажу як є
сьогодні говоримо з начальником
Миколаївської обласної військової
адміністрації Віталієм кімом Вітаю вас
Доброго дня скажи відверто коли Ви
зайшли Я одразу намагалася розгледіти в
яких ви шкарпетках
чи часом не в тих славнозвісних про які
багато писали і говорили які стали
правда народним мемом в одному з
інтерв'ю ви розповідали що у вас є
хотіли купити за 5 тисяч доларів так для
аукціону але ми їх я їх викинув
Наступного дня бо як то кажуть в житті
кожного чоловіка є такий період коли ж
шкарпетки дешевше купити ніж попрати
тому в той час це було так до речі зараз
вже це популярний спосіб допомоги
збройним силам України актори футболісти
співаки продають свої речі на
благодійних аукціонах чи не думали ви
теж долучитися до цього руху
дивіться ми це робимо Але ми не робимо
це особисто бо немає цього часу ми даємо
речі для організації благодійних друзям
які там продають їх на аукціонах ну це
було більш поширено раніше коли було
дуже потрібна допомога Скажем так і я
так по пам'яті скажу що картина яка була
вижила після обстрілу будівлі Ода там
Богдана Хмельницького наскільки я
пам'ятаю на аукціоні Франції продали за
8 мільйонів гривень ці гроші Пішли всі
ЗСУ тобто багато ми віддаємо речі а вони
привозять після аукціону вже щось для
сенсу іноді навіть не в наших регіон бо
ну це не важливо насправді
у 5 місяців відтоді як Миколаїв став
тиловим містом як тут змінилося життя
Чим зараз живе Миколаїв
Миколаїв вже живе надію перемогою вірою
в перемогу тому що всі люди повернулися
сюди всі більшість людей повернулися
сюди Саме через те що вони вірять наші
збройні сили що перемога вже близько і
вони починають облаштовуватись і
готуватися до мирного життя отвечать про
те що більшість людей повернулися і в
Миколаєв Я так розумію в області яка
ситуація з роботою зараз
погана ми працюємо над тим щоби
створювати робочі місця з міжнародними
партнерами з офісом президента Тобто це
і з урядом це є програма які потрібні
важко так казати але мобілізація
допомагає Тому зараз з одного боку
нестачі робочих місць з другого боку
нестача спеціалістів бо багато людей
пішли добровольцями воювати багато пішли
по мобілізації тому на зараз це ще не
катастрофа просто не хвачає на не
вистачає фахівців Але після нашої
Перемоги це водночас стано проблемою для
всієї країни вважаю ну ні десь для
прифронтових точно регіонів які
підприємства і Бізнес який постраждав
тому ми вже працюємо над тим щоб
створювати робочі місця хоча б якісь
Скажімо так у нас є успіхи є відкриття
міжнародної клімової там і пекарень і
таке і таке інше ми всіх просимо і
потрохи воно робить це в Миколаєві
відкрили зараз а в області в області це
саме дити-окупованій частині чи в
принципі по області всі пріоритетна для
докупованих і всі проекти зараз з метою
недоокупованих територій Але ми не
виключаємо тих можливостей
чистих ну скажемо так північних частин
нашого регіону де в принципі там
наприклад бізнес погоджується відкрити
через те що там безпечніше на вашу думку
решта жителів Миколаєва і області повер
неться сюди вже після перемоги після
завершення війни
важке питання Не знаю тому що зараз з
460 близько 400 плюс тисяч повернувся в
місто Миколаїв області ситуація ще краще
там близько 30 тисяч це з переселенці з
Херсона з них можливо частина людей яка
не повернеться яка за кордоном там
молодь На жаль а можливо всі повернуться
Маю надію що всі повернутися на
відбудову нашої держави зараз у світі і
в Україні дуже багато розмов про
Контрнаступ
ви слідкуєте за цими новинами І взагалі
Які у вас очікування від Контрнаступ
А це Ну тому що я не тільки слідкую Я
приймаю часткову участь в інформаційні
там важливо я
ми допомагаємо всім Чим можемо кожен на
своєму фронті для того щоб це
реалізувалося тому ми працюємо на
контурнаступ і на нашу перемогу Напевно
ви слідкуєте за реакціями росіяни їхніми
очікуваннями і побоюваннями Розкажіть
будь ласка як вам
їхні настрої
від Києва за три дні до бомблять Кремль
Ну ось їх приблизно настрої зміни в
настрою додам ну скажемо це можна казати
там факт які були нещодавно наприклад
збили всі ракети там 18-18 із них шість
Це кинджали які неможливо бутило раніше
збити це ж факти який дуже шкодить
настрою росіян тому що і так можливо
буде відбуватися збиття 6 і 6 кинджалів
це
подія в військовому сенсі той же значище
і це все інструменти для подовження ну
для роботи нашу перемогу 11 травня
Україна отримала ракети від Британії
ракети великої дальності на вашу думку
чи зможуть ці ракети переломити хід
війни як це колись було із хаймарсами
наприклад
не можу сказати про кількість і
дальність які саме ракети отримали але
ваше порівняння з фермерсом воно гарне
тобто з точки зору технологічного та
можливостей скажемо так можливості в нас
будуть кращі Ось так я змажую відповісти
на це питання А в якому сенсі В якому
напрямку ну це питання до збройних сил і
значно думаю пізніше але ви щось знаєте
так ми всі щось знаємо але я підписував
ми розповсюдження інформації
порядок
роботи з секретною інформацією назвемо
це так і в нас є порядок взаємодії тому
те що мене не стосується я не коментую
на вашу думку якої зброї бракує Україні
для того щоб здійснити успішний
Контрнаступ і звільнити території які
зараз тимчасово окуповані ядерною зброєю
якою в нас забрали
Давайте так якщо там з максимальною
точки зору Я не прибічник всіх цих
махань ядерної зброї але це жарти але що
стосується зброї які не вистачає це
планує генштаб там Міністерство оборони
ми втрачаємо людей ми втрачаємо героїв
Росія втрачає непотреб свій тому дуже
багато хлопців пішло 24-го числа Тут
були реально всій країні черги вони всі
працюють там
віддаючи своє життя тобто техніка - це
гарна це дуже необхідно але
основна проблема в часі тому ми тривалий
час вимірювали війну там не в територіях
не в днях а в жертвах Тобто це питання
інше нам чим швидше тим краще тому щоб
було швидше нам треба більше збро ю це
убезпечує життя наших солдатів тому Тут
таке питання росіяни просто не рахуються
солдат вони їм нічого не потрібно просто
люди
е-е які нам потрібно техніка щоб
захистити людей щоб не втрачати їх тобто
У нас різні пріоритети от навіть у
військових діях До речі яким ви бачите
шлях до звільнення поки тимчасово
окупованого Криму це все-таки перемовини
чи силовий метод я навпростоюсь бачу
тобто 300 км такий інше ну це теж доволі
складне питання не мо- на мого рівня ми
виконуємо завдання і з точки зору
безпеки Миколаївської області чим далі
ворог від Криму з тої сторони тим краще
тобто я вважаю що так якби було сказано
що перемога це кордони 91-го року це
безпека але безпекових гарантій для
України і вступ до НАТО Тобто це є
перемога яка в повному сенсі може бути і
буде України нині на миколаївщині
окупованою залишається Кінбурнська коса
яка там зараз ситуація і чи є загроза
звідти можливо дуже часто поросята так
яка вірогідні зустріти крокодила за
кутом 50%. Тобто можна зустріти можна Ні
загроза існує з нападу з кінберзької
коси але мало вірогідна на зараз і саме
звідти обстрілюють Очаківську
коцуропської громади Майже щодня
Слава Богу жертв мало
поранених теж мало але це відбувається
Майже щодня
вважаю що
неможливо з тієї сторони зробити якийсь
наступ на нашу сторону але ми повинні
бути готові до всього і саме всі
доктрини ми маємо зробити все навіть
розуміючи що це мало ймовірно До речі як
живуть ті громади які постійно
обстрілюють ви зараз їх почали
перелічили яка там ситуація зараз якщо
писати про Очаків як там був тиждень чи
тільки назад тому там з 15 тисяч
приблизно 7 тисяч знаходиться в місті
багато людей живуть поруч просто 10 км
від'їжджають сусідні громади воно
відбудовуються там будуються укриття
працює АТБ Люди там живуть Тобто ми всі
призвичаїлися до цього На жаль
неприємного темпу в житті але люди не
готові виїжджати навіть з-під таких з
таких населених пунктів як Бахмут люди
не хочуть виїжджати і там зовсім інша
ситуація по обстрілам і по ризику для
життя Тому треба все порівнювати тому що
коли ти живеш далеко тобі страшніше ніж
ти тут живеш тиждень ти перший тиждень
боїшся потім всі інші тижні ти не
реагуєш
спілкуючись з вами ну неможливо не
спитати про наболіло питання яке
тягнеться більше року яка ситуація з
водою
так питання дуже класно тому що ми його
не можемо про це казати я повинні
дочекатися поки інформаційно скаржаться
офіс президента але
урядом його Всім президентом це питання
вирішено але треба його реалізувати ще
певний час але не дочекати поки офіс про
це скажу чим не жалкуєте ви про своє
рішення
щодо того щоб заповнити трубопровід
соленою водою з лиману тому що це
рішення зазнало критики
90% води використовується технічною люди
потерпали від незручності коли набирали
носили питну воду тобто з 10 літрів ти
літ ну там два типєш 20 ти виконуєш для
люди просто в 10 раз менше носили води Я
вважаю що це рішення правильно тому що
не було гуманітарної катастрофи не було
ніяких екологічної витрати грошей це
зрозуміло будемо відновлювати саме це
якраз і вирішується вирішилась
вирішується тому я вважаю що це рішення
було правильно А якщо озирнутися назад і
так ретро потрібно оглянути на минулий
рік чи були рішення про які ви жалкуєте
є рішення які я б зробив ще жорсткіше і
жалкую що не виконав їх тоді скажемо так
тобто
в іншу сторону а які це наприклад ну це
стосується там дисципліни військової
тематиці і контролю ситуації через брак
якийсь досвіту там військового Тому це
не велика кількість рішень але якщо
ставиться Таким чином то я більше жалкую
що треба було б ще більше там зробити в
той час там коли оце було потрібно зараз
ні зараз все в робочому порядку Ми в
Миколаєві сьогодні вже другий
день сторанів як загалом ситуація із
бізнесом чи повертається бізнес великий
бізнес коли є попит тоді є пропозицією
На жаль великий бізнес дуже сильно
постраждав чи перелокован або той і інше
і важко йому розвиватися відновлюватися
в прифронтовій зоні Скажімо так Це
питання часу два великі заводи зараз
відбудовуються але це лише частина
бізнесу який відбудовується що
стосується середнього бізнесу я оцінюю
Де приблизно 50% зараз в закладів
закриті через те що немає достатнього
попиту і важко працювати в мінус як
тільки буде
попит більше все повичиняється ну зараз
йде набір оскільки я знаю МакДональдз
відчиняється там підприємства масове
люди набирають
людей працювати
для того щоб відновлюватися якщо
порівнювати тиждень за тиждень кожного
тижня щось відкривається знову це війна
і тому люди розпоряджаються по-іншому
тому бізнес в Широкому сенсі не може
маленьку розвернутися тому що ну Вони
п'ють так багато людей Ну вони купляють
речей багато непотрібних там прикрас
машин і таке інше все це на 100 це через
військові дії і це добре тому що гроші
треба економити чи віддавати на збройні
сили на початку травня ви озвучили
інформацію
руйнування загалом такому миколаєву і по
області зокрема йдеться про 11 з
половиною тисяч будівель які ми темпами
зараз відбувається відбудова зараз
запустили
офіс президента є відновлення де є вже
порядок як подавати заявки на
компенсацію створюються комісії в
кожному отг для того щоб це було
демократично і прозоро які визначають
кількість
компенсації там порядок і таке інше вже
є порядок як це відновити ну зараз люди
відновлюють самі ми видаємо ну і ми
робимо і місто робить і добровольці
роблять і матеріали даємо але це все
відновлення не
капітальна А це відновлення для того щоб
це скажемо так
кризи кризовий там золота так покрівлю
щоб не текло так там ОСБ закрити вікна
для того щоб можна було б
жити да А коли закінчиться військові дії
тоді будуть відновляться вже як потрібно
тому це екстреної речі які зараз всі
робляться що стосується відновлення ми
вже стартонули декілька великих проектів
наприклад безсмп зараз відновлюється
може за місяць вже будуть закінчувати ще
одна школа ще одна лікарня 10 проектів
проектування на реконструкції Тобто це
процес іде Я думаю що він повним ходом
восени вже буде йти по великим об'єктам
дуже багато своїми силами відновили там
за допомогою донорів за допомогою
іноземних партнерів держави от До речі
при наземних партнерів хто ще допомагає
фінансово відбудовувати я читала про те
що дані
дані дуже активно співпрацює за що їм
дуже дякую співпрацює Казахстан який
зараз теж відбудовує за свої гроші один
об'єкт Миколаєві співпрацює
це ціла низка країн Ну щоб я не хочу
перечисляти бо якогось мого забути і
буде незручно Ну але через них точно Там
Бельгія Молдова Германія Франція
безліч Крим які з кимось співпрацюємо
які допомагають дійсно вони допомагають
всій Україні в тому числі Миколаєва А
яка ще допомога потрібна регіон що все
що не жалко все все
це є допомога Ну я шуткую щодо там речей
які не потрібні там Ми вже змінюємо
запити тому що з багатьма речами ми вже
самотужки справляємося
першочергово що ми зараз просимо це
інфраструктурні матеріали які потрібні
для відновлення інфраструктури це
будівельна техніка це техніка з поліцією
соціалізована це для перевезення восени
з
дітей в школу то що плануємо все-таки
відновити цей процес як вода по всій
території України тому ми якраз і
відпрацьовуємо те що буде потрібно через
там 3-6 місяців у серпні Минулого року в
одному
часі чи змінили ви якось свою думку з
тих пір Ні не змінив Я розмовляв
російською мовою тому що так було
зручніше для нашого регіону це було
зручні це було зрозуміло для росіян тому
що ми працювали і по психіки росіян теж
атакували їх тому це було потрібно
Скажімо так мова я знаю зі школи в мене
було чудово вчителька купцу Валентина
Володимирівна до тренду там до 97-го
року мова моя не змінилася Це єдине де я
її вивчав я додатково її ніде не вивчав
тому в моїй голові коли я знаю там
дві-три мовою приблизно однакові Мені
байдуже Якою мовою розмовляти тому я не
бачу в цьому проблему через мову Я не
буду більшим чи меншим українцям це
особиста Моя думка я не знаю яка
офіційна але кажу як є знаю що для
багатьох українці батьків для мене
особисто ви були людиною антидепресантом
людиною заспокійливим у перші місяці
після вторгнення А на чому трималися ви
звідки був цей оптиміст бажання Перемоги
Тобто це стиль життя це спосіб
управління це
це полегшено тим що мені
відмінили дрискод Скажімо так державний
Да там бюрократичний було лише мета
досягнення інструменту тому стало легше
працювати і
в такому ритмі Я розумію що це потрібно
для всіх тому я робив Ось і все життя
серйозніше
ваші відео справді були дуже популярними
Я думаю що за популярністю можна
порівняти десь із щоденними
відеозверненнями Володимира Зеленського
Чи якось вплинула ця ваша медійність на
стосунки з президентом
сподіваюсь що ніяк не вплинуло тому що я
йду за президентам Я завжди дивлюсь щоб
зрозуміти що Президент хоче донести
людям і який є по силу саме суть це
перше і ну і все тобто в мене робота Я ж
не
обраний як президент я призначений Тому
це дві великі різниці Я маю Виконувати
свою роботу
Володимир Зеленський був у Миколаєві
якщо я не помиляюсь то поправте мене
будь ласка у червні минулого року і
взимку так
який основний меседж ви для себе
підкреслили в комунікації з президентом
взагалі от основний месенджер для вас і
для Миколаєва миколаївщини візит першої
особи в області завжди подія і честь
регіону тобто він контролює особисто
ситуацію в регіонах виїжджає там я
нічого не виносив я доповідав і те що
вдалося поспілкуватися і розповісти про
ситуацію в регіоні це вже велике плюс
тому що в нього є розуміння цього
особисто тому як ми змінилися це робочий
процес коли голова держави приїжджає в
регіон для того щоб розібратися на місці
в ситуації володіти інформацією
гідність цієї популярності в соцмережах
яка була у вас рік тому мені важко
сказати Що змінилася вона в принципі
основного року але е-е ну багато роботи
і вони не мають можливості зараз там
помандрувати
поспілкуватися
це в основному всі робочі зустрічі
навіть якщо Виїжджаю з району
дуже часто це питання безпеки та ви
відомі свої прямолінійністю
відвертістю Скажіть будь ласка чи був у
вас план евакуації план виїзду з
Миколаєва на випадок якщо би росіяни
все-таки зайшли в Миколаєв прорвали
оборону
я щоб це місто не дурень тому план
завжди є не один вони різні як воно буде
це важко сказати як було воно
відбувалося але План був Ну це він
обов'язково мав би бути але є команди є
позиція принципова це вже Інше питання
але ж ви не ви
їжджали
так якщо то можна рахувати 10 км від
Миколаєва миколаївщини Ми навіть
виїжджали ближче до них бо там було
безпечніше ніж в Миколаєві Ну тому що
воно перелітало А тобто
летить ноги я зрозуміла Ну зараз я можу
казати
я зрозуміла А скажіть будь ласка
наскільки вам взагалі було страшно було
здавалося насправді тоді таким
безстрашним А чи було вам страшно
всередині за своє життя
своєрідні за вас переживали до того
моменту коли прийняв рішення що більше
за своє життя Я не боюся Що вплинуло на
прийняття цього рішення
ну просто оцінювали ситуацію що на що ти
готовий піти зараду Там якихось цілей
коли ти для себе приймаєш рішення далі
вже все далі вже все легше
А як ви пережили той день коли російська
ракета прилетіла
якщо б сказати з легкістю Це не зовсім
правда ну як по мене не дуже я
переймався я розумів що це може бути
будь-який момент по людях Дуже жалко
тобто бо люди
по-різному до цього ставились деякі
реально переживали боялися цього і з
деякими це саме сталося ну там хлопець
не буде там про деталь там хлопець з
связи з нього День народження або в цей
день ну тобто ситуація різні ситуації
погана - це один із гірших днів за цей
час Що стосується мене особисто
про перемогу
якою ви її бачите прекрасно
кордону в 91-го року з гарантіями
безпеки для України і з вступом до НАТО
це якщо брати про покрокове далі далі
кордони 91-го року це супер на рік
щонайменше якщо це буде гарантія безпеки
це рік і років п'ять якщо це нато То це
назавжди Як думаєте в нас чекають
безумовно тому що тому що ми б'ємося
краще ніж багато хто тому що в нас там
чекають І ми готові бути частиною НАТО
якщо я можу це казати за країну я так
вважаю що ми готові бути частиною НАТО і
відстоювати безпеку Європи Що Ми зараз
робимо разом зі всіма Дякую вам за це
роз